è la tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono perchè sto
facendo uno io sono qua vj oggi siamo su
scriverlo zam est
eravamo rimasti ragazzi che avevano
battuto lex luthor che era stato perché
ci osti stivali marroni molto sexy
non lo so ragazzi comunque va bene la
gara vamo rimasti che avevamo battuto
lex luthor è praticamente ragazzi mi
avete consigliato di fare una specie di
episodio tra virgolette nel cuore aiuto
la gente perché mi avete letto che sono
i momenti più divertenti
se devo essere sincero ragazzi la parte
di aiutare le persone quella che mi
piace di più perché succede sempre
voglio che togliamo lisca questo museo
aerospaziale sinceramente amica mia non
so che cosa sa fatto sta roba ma va bene
gli struzzi mi serve un altro un
attrezzo per ricostruirlo perché cazzo
mai fatto distruggere allora visto che
me l'hai fatto distruggere mi ha fatto
sprecare del tempo al recente lo
ricostruisce con un cacciavite minuscolo
[Musica]
ok non che cazzo sta su cos'è ha
ricostruito ti sta bene stronzo di merda
io non ho idea di come diavolo abbia
fatto ricostruire centro aerospaziale
con un cacciavite in un nanosecondo
maglie lo distruggo così perché sono
cattivo qualcuno mi aiuti sono stato
legato a questa colonna e lasciato a
marcire chi cazzo sei
e vabbè raccoglie grande allora essendo
affetta fermo fermo cazzo non ti lascerò
morire
raga eh vabbè è morto ormai facciamo c'è
una ragione ma perché sto prendendo
danni così a caso ma che belli siete
ragazzi mi serve un travestimento ad
attese ad un travestimento perfetto
costume metto il mio perché bellissimo
in far bene non è esattamente quello che
ti ho fabbricato ma non importa se ti
piace va bene ok crostate calmi e molto
calmi ragazzi che sta diventando
incazzata nera voglio aiutare a
combattere il crimine poi darmi qualcosa
che un eroe posso dare pollo di gomma
ragazzi questo questo è largo questa è
l'arma migliore di un eroe non puoi non
puoi non apprezzarla ciao zio come stai
cycle sacco naz.le stiamo ricevendo i
nuovi allarmi si è pronto a procedere se
vuoi andare qui alla watch tower a nola
andiamo alla watch tower non so che cosa
può servire ma va bene raga siamo alla
stalla non c'è anche una star heights
robin cazzo vogliono autografo
vabbè ma che cazzo serve ma dai raga io
faccio una storia perché non ho ancora
capito
simon versus the thing benissimo di tosi
sono stati trovati ma cosa vogliono
cyborg ho trovato gli intrusi sono
destro che dopo il genscher chi cazzo è
fermo dove 66 slade ragazzi via le luci
cyborg c'è sempre da per granger ragazzi
che rompe costantemente le palle ragazzi
lo prenderò a calci prima o poi maxwell
si dirigono verso il campo di
contenimento di amazon ma lì ti
raggiungo dopo va bene cyborg
non ti preoccupare cyborg ci penso io
come si deve
ok forse un piccolo aiutino mi
servirebbe ragazzi pensano di fottermi
costa trappola ma non sanno con chi
hanno a che fare laga non ne hanno idea
tagliamo con le forbici i fili vabbè
perfetto dove due casi è qui
macché furbo 6 saltato dentro una buca
ma bravo questo dovrebbe rallentarti chi
cazzo che cosa fanno
ma perché devono rompere le palle a me è
bello bellissimo
lui non sa che io ho un pollo di gomma
che può aiutarmi situazioni veramente
gravi c'è grande paul vede ragazzi il
pollo di gomma voi non lo sapete ma è
l'arma al numero 1 in questi casi va beh
ci siamo ragazzi lo sono riuscire
perfetto grande pollo questo ti per me
ragazzi non potete nulla contro i folli
amico mio
dammi una mano come si deve vai cos'è
grandi il po io amo i polli di gomma
sono innamoratissimo da adesso in avanti
saranno il mio alleato numero uno potevi
passare maledetti non potete maschi è
quello ci siamo quasi
chi cazzo è questo se vi sembra beh bene
avete liberato un gigante un attimo dove
deve essere dietro ad amazon non mi
pagano abbastanza per affrontare amazon
e ce ne andiamo
cos'è cioè io adesso me lo becco io sto
colosso grandissimi ga perfetto dammi la
mano non posso sconfiggerlo da solo
ragazzi mi ha chiesto di dargli una mano
e io faccio così perché altro non posso
fare che tieni perfetto se penso che
funzioni sapendo non funziona la malfa a
manate nel culo vai cos'è grandissimi
mentono per riuscirci ma ce l'hai fatta
grazie maxwell a maggio avrebbe fatto a
pezzi la mostra è perfetta non importa
io io risolvo la situazione stiamo
quello st wright rega voglio fare una
cosa deve essere quello per cui erano
venuti si perfetto lo prendo io ora
voglio fare una cosa non possa st wright
serie madonna come felice ragazzi voglio
riuscire a fare una cosa se riesco
perché diciamo che ci tengo parecchio
adesso capirete che cosa aspetta che
colpisce tutti gli gnomi sei pronto ci
regala fa la fabbrica di gnomi dai
mancato uno la fortuna di assistere
meglio la prossima volta ma no dai cazzo
mi date il tempo c'era un uomo armato di
ascia volevo buttarlo giù come si deve
io ho sempre giocato da kia palo l'uomo
sempre vinto aiuta a far sentire
mia voce microfono che cazzo vuoi di più
vai continuo grande balena canterina vai
così billy conquistiamo al mondo è
tornato anche lui perché ovviamente non
poteva mancare e cioè cos'è c'è il
cavallo di [ __ ] 66 mica kill senti
amico mio legionario consegna questo
cavallo di [ __ ] all'impianto di
trattamento delle acque di mongol
dovrebbe essere quello questo la in
fondo ce lo devo spingerlo in acqua in
poche parole va bene lo spingere i narco
al cavallo di [ __ ] non chiedetevi
perché vai ville vuoi vedere che se mi
che è più potente di un cavallo di [ __ ]
cioè fatemi capire che ci siamo io l'ho
buttato in acqua come richiesta per non
rompere le palle ragazzi sta diventando
sempre più assurdo più modo cos'è sta
roba cos'è devo vincere la pallavolo
contro sto tizio servi palla da
pallavolo oltre la rete del campo brutto
stronzo vinto io ma vj antisportivo se
perché te ne vai malanotti sicilia non
ti suicidare ragazzi che cosa non si fa
quando si perde una partita al giorno
d'oggi se perdete una partita non
incazzatevi perché si sta mega o perché
c'è un pinguino che sta ci sta chi cazzo
trovami un mezzo di forse o in alla
volta prendete il biglietto cazzola che
posso servire tutti ed dammi un mezzo
veloce da mila per sull ora facciamo
così perché sennò flash è una
accontentato ci siamo
1 c'è l'altro che cazzo fai bingo iozzi
non ho mai visto un pinguino occorre le
costiere
vabbè sentite io non so chi cazzo
aiutare ma nel dubbio vi presento il mio
amico trampolino che ritorno allo
scritto el 8 al limite tragga sarà un
disastro tua è inutile che ti disperi
perché se ti lancio questo son cazzi
tuoi
ragazze trappolino è sempre fantastico
dove 62 chi prega o poi gioco il gioco
ragazzi mi sa che ho baciato il gioco
non ne sono sicuro mio zio che salto
era tutto calcolato ragazzi per finire
qui sopra o delle informazioni per te ma
hanno un prezzo allora ti do un coupon
per andare a vedere i one direction
gratis su marte dove giovedì perfetto
allora ragazzi spero vada bene grumosi
che cazzo mucose col suicida redditi di
randy rettile o obesa ragazzi spero vada
bene lo stesso ragazzi più osservo sto
uccello correre e più mi chiedo perché
sto ancora giocando a questo gioco
dacci un edificio per difenderci vecchia
testo condominio non sa se ti serve a
qualcosa ma spero di sì
ecco ecco li na li che si fanno ok forse
non era abbastanza resistente la loggia
non massacrati di brutto qualcuno mi
aiuti
c'è qualcosa che non va bastardi e hanno
teso un'imboscata
vabbè questa questa me la pagano mela
pagano buco nero brutti stronzi entrate
qui dentro ragazzi ok imboscate vista
mio dio sono stato un genio un genio
tutti loro ho risucchiato tutti quanti
in un colpo solo rega sta diventando
cos'è c'è un prova a sbattermi fuori dal
ring ti sfido ti piace vincere facile
[Musica]
che cazzo no no che cazzo è ok ok è
successo un disastro
cioè il tizio stava accadendo e c'era
c'era quest'altro che voleva salvarlo
prendendo un al volo ma non c'è riuscita
è caduto anche lui io ero è serve klose
0 ma perché parlano come dei mentecatti
vabbè serve cose da eroe elmo il bel
monte elmo el montico tieni questo estro
ed ero è un serpente con un elmo che
dieci volte grosso quanto lui e con
questo direi che sei pronto a combattere
il crimine ragazzi è l'eroe migliore che
abbia mai visto una ragazza puntata
l'omessa molto più sul cassetto perché
non lo so mi diverto il casinò cos'è
cerco un cambio di coda ma perché sei un
anguilla volante coda di canguro ragazzi
non funzioni carruba non so se cambia
qualcosa cosa parte anatomica
non so che cosa cambia ma spero vada
bene io non ho idea del perché ci sia
una pattumiera
ma questo lo devo fare a paranormal
pattumiera ragazzi è fantastico sognavo
di crearla anche in scribblenauts legame
ne torna alla caverna di batman perché
qui il mio lavoro è finito mi attaccano
i testi nel frattempo va beh ho fatto
tutto quello che dovevo fare oggi dovevo
farlo assolutamente una puntata nel
genere molto più scazzo perché me lo
chiedeva te da tantissimo tempo quindi
va bene
raga concludo qui l'episodio come al
solito se guido è piaciuto lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione sarà se non iscritti
iscrivetevi riuscì vediamolo prossimo
vito bei ragazzi